This is sort of a funny detail about the
presidential transition. Typically during
the inauguration, there's this few hour period
during which furniture is swapped out at the
White House for the incoming president, artwork
is changed. There's a little bit of redecorating
that's done and it's all happening very, very
quickly because of the coronavirus pandemic.
This time around, there's an extra detail, which
is that Joe Biden has already made plans to spray
down the entire White House with disinfectant
in that interim period after Trump leaves and
before Joe Biden arrives. As you probably know,
the White House has been suffering a plague
of covid infections that includes Trump
himself and many other people. I won't
list them. So they're going to go in and hit
the doorknobs and everything. And for me, this
is more about the optics and the poetic meaning of
disinfecting the White House from Trump. Because,
listen, we learned remember early on in the
pandemic where people were bleaching groceries,
including just like boxed groceries, where you
could just open the box anyway. And then we found
out that the surface transmission was really quite
low. That was probably a bit overblown. So for me,
this this is not really about spraying
down the White House with disinfectant,
misting disinfectant to literally prevent someone
who works for Biden from catching the virus from
a surface VVA, someone who works for Trump. For
me, it's more about the poetic meaning of going
through the White House, misting disinfectant
everywhere. It's more about the metaphor of
getting rid of Trump and his failed response to
the pandemic. You still love to see it. The visual
is going to think about his hilarious. But it's
more for me about cleaning the White House, not
literally of Trump's germs, but of the incompetent
leadership of the virus. I'm calling this
fumigate. I'm not even a dad and I was able to
tell that joke. I was actually thinking, though,
so first my thought was maybe Biden should
sleep somewhere else a few days and give it
48, 72 hours before walking into the White House.
But the truth is, Trump may well be gone by then.
This is the other story. And we've been covering
this for the last seven to 10 days. It's still
unclear whether Donald Trump is going to stick
around and actually go to the inauguration.
One other possibility is he will fly out right
before the inauguration directly to a rally at
which he will continue to claim he won or maybe
even announce his twenty twenty four candidacy.
That would be completely corrosive to
democracy. He might also head to Florida
in just about 10 or 15 days for Christmas and
New Year and just not come back to Washington,
D.C. That's another speculation. We really don't
know and we don't care as long as he leaves. Now,
if I were Biden to be safe, I would spray I would
treat for bedbugs. I would check for electronic
bugs as well. Check for false paneled walls,
check Melania's Rose Garden for listening devices,
put the solar panels back on. I would do the
whole thing if I were Joe Biden and think about
how quickly things have changed where at the
beginning of this pandemic. Before any of them
even remotely accepted, this might be a big thing,
Republicans were joking about wearing gas masks.
Remember Matt Gates wearing a big gas mask on the
floor of Congress? He ended up getting the virus.
They were making fun of China, having trucks,
spraying disinfectant. And just months later,
the incoming president is going to have
disinfectant sprayed in much the same manner
throughout the White House to clean it from the
outgoing president. Things change very quickly.
My only concern is let's start figuring this
out. Let's get competent leadership. We know
that Joe Biden is going to mandate masks at
federal buildings. We know Joe Biden is going
to ask Americans to wear masks for 100 days. We
are hoping that we will start getting five, six,
seven percent of the US population vaccinated
each month, hopefully starting this month,
maybe only a few percent this month, and
five, six, seven, eight percent in January,
another five to eight percent in February. And
we're going to we're going to start hopefully
the economic recovery will come with it. We're
going to talk about second coronavirus stimulus.
We're going to be here and there's going to be so
much to do. But this transition is metaphorical.
And as much as of a sense as it
is literal, let me know what you
think. I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we've got a great show for you today,